Salzburg has plenty of beautiful things to
offer: mountains, a Baroque town centre, an
impressive medieval fortress - and one of
Austria's best-known shopping streets: Getreidegasse.
Tour guide Inez Reichl has a few tips on where
the locals like to go.
Café Classic, for instance.
"The hot chocolate here is my favourite.
The Café Classic is on the ground floor of
the house where Mozart lived.
Not many people know about it.
It's a place locals enjoy - and I'm one of
them."
+++
The first floor of the building called the
Mozart Residence houses museum pieces.
You can only touch the keys of these instruments
if you have special permission.
"This is the Mozart family's old pianoforte.
Wolfgang himself played on it."
Steingasse is also largely unknown to tourists,
even though it's in the oldest part of Salzburg.
The first houses were built here in the 11th
century.
These distinctive grooves are much newer.
"They were made after World War Two, when
the Americans were here in Salzburg.
The GIs, the young soldiers, tried to drive
into this narrow lane with a tank, because
there was a brothel back there.
Unfortunately, the GIs had had a few beers,
got stuck, and had to be towed out.
People here found it so funny that they left
the marks."
The people of Salzburg aren't just proud of
their history.
The Museum of Modern Art, at first a controversial
construction, has attracted thousands of visitors
since 2004.
"First of all, its location is fantastic.
From up here you have a great view over the
city.
And then I think it's incredibly important
that in addition to the baroque, the old and
traditional, we have new things, and the museum
is the perfect place for that."
And here's a relaxing way to end your day
in Salzburg : in "M32," the restaurant in
the museum building.